en este vídeo quiero platicar acerca de
polinomios déjame ponerle por aquí
polinomios polinomios y polinomios
parece una palabra muy complicada pero
un polinomio simplemente es la suma de
algunos términos que tiene constantes y
variables en donde las variables están
elevadas a exponentes que son enteros
positivos sí creo que ya dije algo un
poco más complicado bueno vamos a ver
mejor algunos ejemplos para explicar a
qué me refiero digamos si tenemos la
expresión x al cuadrado x al cuadrado
más 1 entonces esto de aquí es un
polinomio de hecho es un binomio porque
tiene dos términos polinomio se refiere
a algo un poco más general este poli
viene de muchos es algo que tiene muchos
términos déjame poner otro ejemplo
digamos si tenemos 4 x al cubo
4 x al cubo menos 2 x cuadrada
+ 7 entonces esto de aquí también es un
polinomio de hecho es un trinomio porque
tiene tres términos pero creo que
también es útil ver ejemplos de algunas
cosas que no son polinomios por ejemplo
x a la menos un medio x a la menos un
medio más uno no es un polinomio le voy
a poner aquí que no es un polinomio
porque este exponente no es un entero
positivo queremos puros exponentes que
sean entre los positivos como 223 y así
entonces esto de aquí no es un polinomio
esto no quiere decir que no te lo vas a
encontrar cuando hagas problemas
matemáticos pero simplemente no se llama
polinomio vale de manera similar ye yé
raíz cuadrada de i
menos cuadrada este de aquí tampoco
tampoco es un polinomio porque llegué a
la
raíz cuadrada de y es lo mismo que
elevar a un medio entonces otra vez
tenemos exponentes que no son enteros
positivos va entonces ninguno de estos
dos ejemplos es un polinomio muy bien
ahora ya viendo más o menos algunos
ejemplos de cosas que si son y cosas que
no son polinomios vamos a pasar a un
poco de la terminología va para que
sepamos a qué se refieren algunas
palabras vamos a empezar con el grado el
grado de un poli no lo voy a poner por
aquí creado grado el grado de un
polinomio simplemente es el máximo
exponente que tiene el polinomio por
ejemplo aquí arriba el máximo exponente
que tenemos es 3 y por lo tanto decimos
decimos que esto de acá es un polinomio
de grado 3 le voy a poner así es un
polinomio le voy a poner nada más poli
de grado
de grado 3 y de manera similar el
polinomio de aquí arriba a su máximo
exponente es 2 y lo voy a marcar el 3 y
por lo tanto este es un polinomio de
grado 2 polinomio de grado grado 2 a
éste también se le conoce como polinomio
cúbico y al de arriba como polinomio
cuadrado bueno entonces el grado es es
el máximo exponente que otras cosas pues
también los polinomios tienen términos
constantes y términos variables por
ejemplo aquí estos dos son términos
variables porque tienen equis pero este
de acá el 7 sería un término constante
porque nada más es un número así
constante de manera similar este de aquí
también es constante este aquí es
constante y este de aquí es un término
variable y finalmente déjame platicar
acerca de los coeficientes de un
polinomio y para esto voy a poner otro
ejemplo porque ya escribí mucho sobre
estos entonces voy a poner un ejemplo un
poco en desorden y dice x al cuadrado
- 5 x + 7 x a la quinta menos 5 ok
entonces aquí tenemos otro polinomio
cuál es el grado el grado es 5 verdad 5
es el exponente más grande que tenemos y
entonces déjame le pongo que es un
polinomio de grado 5 polinomio de grado
de grado
de grado 5 y bueno o sea es que te
preguntarás por qué es tan importante el
grado porque porque me estoy fijando
tanto en el grado bueno hay varias cosas
por las cuales es importante pero para
mí lo que nos dice es qué sucede con el
polinomio cuando x es muy muy grande
vale entonces el término que tiene el
exponente más grande va a dominar al
resto de los términos más o menos la
idea detrás es que es que éste esté
bueno este este término el que tiene el
exponente más grande nos dice qué tan
rápido crece o decrece el polinomio
decrece en el caso en el que este
coeficiente sea negativo pero claro
coeficientes no he platicado de eso
entonces deja pongo por aquí abajo
coeficientes
coeficientes deficientes y ya habíamos
utilizado esta palabra antes verdad
cuando hablamos de sistemas de
ecuaciones y los coeficientes
básicamente son los números o bien las
constantes que acompañan a cada término
variable por ejemplo aquí tenemos que el
coeficiente es menos 5 el coeficiente de
este término menos 5x es menos 5 con
todo y el menos vale así lo vamos a
pensar el coeficiente aquí sería 7 y
aquí sería menos 5 aquí no está la equis
pero podemos pensar que hay un x a la
cero y por lo tanto el menos 5 es lo que
acompaña a la equis y qué pasa con este
término de aquí pues aquí el coeficiente
es uno solo que pues bueno no no no
tiene sentido poner el 1 porque porque
pues ya implícitamente tenemos una
multiplicación por 1 pero cuando no
tenemos un coeficiente visible quiere
decir que hay un coeficiente 1 detrás
vale ok
nada más una última cosa déjame
platicarte de la forma estándar de un
polinomio voy a ponerlo por acá voy a
escribirlo con este color azul
la forma forma estándar
estándar
y la forma estándar de un polinomio
básicamente es escribir sus términos
pero en orden decreciente de exponente
vale o sea tenemos que ir bajando de
exponente
por ejemplo para escribir este polinomio
en forma estándar empezamos con el de
exponente más grande el de mayor grado
que sería este 7x a la quinta le voy a
poner aquí 7 x a la quinta luego
tendríamos que ir a este al cuadrado
verdad porque es el siguiente con
exponente más grande sería más x al
cuadrado le podría poner más 1 x al
cuadrado pero nada más lo voy a dejar
así y luego vamos a éste que es menos 5
x
- 5x y finalmente voy a poner este de
acá que es menos 5 menos 5 muy bien
entonces aquí ya está escrito el
polinomio de aquí arriba en forma
estándar o sea con orden decreciente de
exponentes muy bien ahora bueno todas
estas definiciones todavía no te sirven
para nada para resolver un problema pero
es muy útil que las tengas en cuenta
para después cuando yo platiqué algunos
problemas de polinomios o tu maestro los
platiqué para que sepas a qué nos
estamos refiriendo va ahora si vamos a
pasar a algunas operaciones y estas
operaciones son muy muy útiles muy muy
útiles no sólo para polinomios sino para
toda toda tu vida matemática entonces
bueno vamos a sumar y restar polinomios
ya habíamos algunos ejemplos en vídeos
anteriores vamos a ver unos ejemplos más
imagínate que nos piden sumar el
polinomio menos 2 x cuadrada más 4 x
menos 12 más 4 x menos 12 con el
polinomio con el polinomio 7
+ x al cuadrado lo único importante para
recordar cuando tenemos que hacer estas
cosas cuando tenemos que sumar
polinomios es clínicamente podemos sumar
términos en los cuales las variables
tengan pues el mismo grado ahorita nada
más tenemos una variable que es x pero
ahorita hacemos un ejemplo más
complicado con varias variables entonces
bueno vamos a hacer eso pero antes
déjame quitar los paréntesis ahorita los
paréntesis no nos sirven de nada porque
esto es una suma entonces vamos a
quitarlo para que se vea un poco más
limpio si tuviéramos una resta hay que
tener cuidado con distribuir el signo
menos ahorita hacemos un ejemplo de eso
pero este quitando los paréntesis aquí
me queda menos 2x cuadrada
+ 4 x menos 12 + 7 x + x al cuadrado muy
bien aquí ya podemos juntar términos
similares déjame tomar este color rosa
entonces vamos a empezar con los
términos de mayor grado para que ya
quede en forma estándar va entonces
tenemos aquí menos 2 x cuadrada y aquí x
cuadrado las voy a escribir aquí menos 2
x cuadrada más x 4 muy bien esos son los
términos con exponente 2 ahora voy a
tomar este color morado para indicar los
términos que tienen nada más x a la 1
que serían este más 4 x y este más 7 x
ba y finalmente con este color azul voy
a marcar el término constante que es
este menos 2
este menos 2 verdad no menos 12 mira
copia mal aquí esté uno éste es menos
menos 12 a qué bueno que me di cuenta
tiempo bueno ahora sí vamos a sumar
estos términos iguales estos términos
iguales y esto y este término entonces
que nos quedaría nos quedaría menos 2 x
cuadradas más x cuadradas y tenemos
menos 2 de algo y le sumamos 1 obtenemos
- x cuadrado o bien si aún no le
quitamos 2 obtenemos - x cuadradas
vamos con este de ak-47 de 11 tenemos 11
x y finalmente el término constante nos
queda menos 12 entonces la suma la suma
de estos dos polinomios es menos x
cuadrada a más 11 x menos 12 el
coeficiente principal que es el
coeficiente del término de mayor grado
del término principal es menos 1 el
coeficiente de este término es 11 y este
de acá el término constante es menos 12
muy bien ya está en forma estándar muy
bonito todo y parece ser que fue
sencillo verdad vamos a hacer un ejemplo
un poco más complicado que involucre
varias variables y una resta pares o
déjame bajar un poquito y lo voy a poner
aquí entonces el problema dice lo
siguiente dice haz la siguiente resta de
polinomios de 2 a cuadrada b -3 ave
cuadrada
tres aves cuadradas más cinco a cuadrada
de cuadrada
de cuadrada este es el primer polinomio
y a eso queremos restar 2 al cuadrado de
cuadrada 2 a cuadrada de cuadrada más 4
a cuadrada bien 4a 4b 5b cuadradas 5b
cuadrada
entonces ahora tenemos aquí una resta y
tenemos dos variables entonces vamos a
hacer las cosas con calma lo primero que
yo haría es distribuir este signo menos
cambiándole el signo a cada uno de estos
términos para entonces déjame reescribir
esta expresión como lo primero lo
dejamos igual 2 al cuadrado
3 b cuadrada más 5 a cuadrada b cuadrada
y ahora tenemos que distribuir este
menos nos quedaría menos 2 a cuadrada b
luego de cuadrada luego menos 4 a
cuadrada de menos 4 al cuadrado
y luego este menos con este menú se hace
más
5b cuadrada muy bien entonces aquí ya
tenemos la operación que tenemos que
realizar vamos a simplificar la entonces
tenemos que sumar términos similares
déjame juntarlos y voy a empezar con
este color azul entonces empecemos con
términos de la forma cuadrada b
hay algún otro término de la forma
cuadrada para que podamos sumar o restar
tienen que coincidir los exponentes de
ambas variables tiene que ser cuadrada y
ve a ver este noroeste no esté no esté
si éste está cuadrada ve este menos 4 a
cuadrada b entonces los copió con 2a
cuadrada b menos 4 a cuadrada ve muy
bien ahora vamos a las cosas del estilo
menos tres ave cuadrada estaría acá
menos tres ave cuadrada hay otro a b
cuadrada pues no no verdad éste está
cuadrada ave cuadrada este también y
este es b cuadrada entonces nada más
está el menos 3 a b cuadrada luego
tenemos estos términos de acá
que los voy a pintar en color amarillo
los de la forma cuadrada ve y tenemos 5
al cuadrado
y aquí tenemos menos 2 al cuadrado más 5
a cuadrada b cuadrada a la cuadrada de
cuadrada perdón menos 2 a cuadrada b
cuadrada y finalmente y finalmente
tenemos este que es más 5 b cuadrada y
ya no hay ninguno más desistir entonces
vamos a realizar las operaciones para
ver cuánto nos queda dos menos cuatro es
menos dos menos 2 al cuadrado b luego es
menos 3 ave cuadrada en los tres a b
cuadrada luego en color amarillo es 5
menos dos que nos queda tres a cuadrada
b cuadrada y finalmente hay que sumar 5
b cuadrado más 5 b cuadrada y a lo mejor
te preguntarás si esto ya está en forma
estándar porque no hemos platicado de la
forma estándar cuando hay más de una
variable y bueno depende mucho del gusto
hay las hay personas que lo hacen de una
forma hay personas que lo hacen de otra
a mí me gusta pensarlo como la
combinación
de los grados de las dos variables
entonces lo que yo haría es poner
primero este 3 y ponerlo en el color
amarillo 3 a cuadrada ave cuadrada
porque el grado conjunto es 4 luego
pondría estos que tienen grado conjunto
3 no importa cual cual primero voy a
poner primero el azul no sería menos 2 a
cuadrada b luego sería este menos 3 ave
cuadrada
y finalmente pondría el término naranja
término naranja que es más 5 b cuadrada
por qué grado combinado nada más es 2
vale muy bien entonces aquí ya lo
tenemos en una cierta forma está listo
ya resolvimos este problema que estaba
un poco más complicado ya nada más para
terminar el vídeo
quiero enseñarte un ejemplo de cómo
construir polinomios a partir de dibujos
y esto es más o menos para que veas que
nuestras representaciones abstractas
pues si tienen alguna utilidad tienen
utilidad en cálculo o en geometría en
álgebra y en un montón de partes más
entonces el problema dice lo siguiente
dice representa el área de cada una de
las figuras en términos de un polinomio
ok voy a intentar hacerlo con los mismos
colores que aquí dan entonces voy a
empezar con esta primera figura si
queremos el área de la parte coloreada
tenemos que poner el área de este
rectángulo que es x
y a eso tenemos que sumarle el área de
estos rectángulos de estos rectángulos
amarillos entonces el área de uno de
ellos es x x zeta pero tenemos 22 x 71
aquí y 1 acá entonces esta sería la
primera respuesta ahora vamos con este
en este a ver aquí tenemos estos cuatro
rectángulos que son iguales que son de
medidas a y b entonces tenemos ave más
ave más ave más ave
sabe muy bien y luego hay que sumar el
área de este cachito verde chin creo que
no nos dan la información a mira que hay
una c estás esta rara aquí no como que
no debería estar aquí déjame ponerle que
está sé que está hace en realidad es
este lado que nos falta para para poder
conocer el área de este de este
rectángulo verde va entonces el área de
este rectángulo verde sería su altura
qué es
sin creo que debería usar un verde más
brillante
por si sale entonces este aporte déjame
simplificar esto nos quedaría igual a 4
veces saben esto es igual a 4 veces
saben
ave
más hace más así muy bien entonces aquí
está el área de la segunda figura en una
expresión del polinomio y asumí que él
hace que nos daban en realidad era de
este lado bueno pasemos a este de acá
estoy acá como sería para encontrar en
el área coloreada de rosa tenemos que
tomar toda el área del rectángulo grande
que sería 2x y 2x y ya eso restarle el
área de estos dos cuadrados y son
cuadrados del lado x y tenemos 2
entonces hay que restarle 2 x al
cuadrado y finalmente en la figura de
aquí abajo
pues ver podemos trazar esta línea esta
línea y esta línea de acá para separar
las áreas y entonces ahora tenemos aquí
un rectángulo de área a b
otro rectángulo de área ave y un tercer
rectángulo de área ave ave y por lo
tanto el área total es 3
muy bien espero que todos estos términos
ejemplos y problemas hayan sido un buen
calentamiento para este tema de
polinomios